- [Voiceover] Hello Grammarians
Hello Paige,
- [Voiceover] Hi, David.
- [Voiceover] Hello apostrophe!
Today we're going to start talking about
a different piece of punctuation
and that piece of
punctuation is the apostrophe
it kind of looks like a comma,
but it's one that floats in the air
Here's the ground, here's the word ground,
And if we say Paige's dog Atti
we're using the apostrophe,
not shown to scale obviously
in one of its three
different applications.
So the apostrophe can do three things.
Thing number one: it can
stand in for missing letters.
- [Voiceover] So when
an apostrophe stands in
for missing letters that's
called a contraction
- [Voiceover] So what does that look like,
what does a contraction
look like in context?
- [Voiceover] So another
way to say something like
"I did not eat the cookie." Is to say
"I didn't eat the cookie."
- [Voiceover] So that
apostrophe there represents
the 'O' being taken out
and everything being
squished together into
this new word 'didn't'
So "Did not" gets (sucks) together,
and then we attach this
apostrophe to show that
we've contracted, or shortened
or shrunk, these two words.
- [Voiceover] Right.
- [Voiceover] Paige, join
me on screen number two
and let's talk about thing number two.
- [Voiceover] Let's go.
- [Voiceover] So the second
thing that an apostrophe can do
is show that something belongs to someone,
what we call possession.
- [Voiceover] So you
can use an apostrophe to
say something like "That's
David's cursed skull."
- [Voiceover] It's true.
It's been in my family for generations.
But what is going on here?
What is this doing the same work as?
- [Voiceover] So the
sentence basically means
that cursed skull belongs to David.
This first sentence, "That's
David's cursed skull"
is kind of just an easier way to say that.
- [Voiceover] So apostrophes
can show contraction
much like we're also doing
in this part of the sentence
as well with "That's",
because this is a shorter version of
"That is David's cursed skull."
but we're condensing that or
contracting that into "That's"
but it's also being used
for its second purpose here
which is "David's", and
this is what we call
the possessive or the genitive case.
Saying that, this cursed
skull belongs to me.
Paige, what's the third
use of apostrophes?
It's pretty rare.
- [Voiceover] The third use
does not happen very often,
but apostrophes can occasionally be used
to make words plural.
- [Voiceover] Okay,
because I was always taught
never to use apostrophes
to pluralize stuff.
Like the plural of book is books,
not "Book's". That's wrong.
- [Voiceover] Yeah, so there a--
- [Voiceover] This is the plural,
and this is something belonging to a book.
- [Voiceover] Right, the book's pages.
- [Voiceover] Right.
- [Voiceover] So there's
really only one case
where you'd want to use an apostrophe
to make something plural.
- [Voiceover] What is that case?
- [Voiceover] That case is when you're
trying to make the plural
of lower case letter.
- [Voiceover] Like, "I'm
really bad at drawing 's's."
- [Voiceover] Right. If you
didn't have that apostrophe
there, it might kinda
just look like (hisses)
- [Voiceover] So I could say, for example,
"I like to draw j's"
and "Remember to dot your j's and i's"
Like that, to denote that their plural,
to indicate there's
some kind of separation
between this lowercase letter
and this lowercase letter.
And that we're trying to say that
there are multiple j's and i's.
- [Voiceover] Right. Especially
with something like i's,
if you didn't have that apostrophe there,
it would probably just look like
you were trying to write the word is.
- [Voiceover] Sure.
So this is kind of a work-around.
- [Voiceover] Exactly.
- [Voiceover] So this
usage is extremely rare,
that's why I put it in parentheses,
because I really want to
de-emphasize this last usage.
Super rare.
So more importantly the first
two things are the most important.
Number one, contractions
make stuff shorter like
"I did not eat the cookie." to
"I didn't eat the cookie."
And possession, showing ownership.
So instead of saying "That
cursed skull belongs to David"
you would say "That is
David's cursed skull."
- [Voiceover] Exactly.
- [Voiceover] And that's an overview
of the three powers of the apostrophe.
You can learn anything, David out.
- [Voiceover] Paige out.